(audience cheering)
- All right, y'all,
we've got one last story
we hope brings a smile to your face.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
It is no secret that I'm a huge advocate
of reading early and reading often,
but there just aren't many books
for kids who are visually impaired.
That's why we want to shine
a light on a Detroit woman
who's printing children's books in braille
and getting them into the hands
of kids all over the world.
It's amazing.
It's the perfect story for
this Braille Literacy month.
Let's say hi to Debra,
the founder of Seedlings
watching on WXYZ TV.
What's up, Debra?
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly.
I was breathing really
fast, I'm so excited.
- Well, we're honored
to have you on the show.
So, why have kids books in braille
been so few and far between?
- You know, that was my question.
Like way back in 1980, I met a
mom whose daughter was blind,
and she said they had a hard
time getting books for her
if they could find them.
They were so expensive, like
100 to $200 each, Kelly.
And that just hurt my heart
because my own kids had, you know,
you can get books for two, $3.
- Yeah.
- And that's what kids need,
lots and lots of books.
So, I thought I could do
something about it maybe.
I started a small nonprofit
in my basement in Detroit
called Seedlings Braille
Books for Children,
making more books available,
keeping the prices really low,
and getting more books in kids' hands.
- Absolutely.
That's such a cool
thing that you're doing.
And you have a portion of Seedlings
that honors your late daughter, right?
Can you tell us about it?
- Yeah, so my daughters were
one and three years old.
They're right around your age, Kelly.
And when I started Seedlings
and then they grew up with it.
They loved books, they suggested titles.
They worked there in high school.
But when the older one,
Anna went off to college,
unfortunately her car
was hit by a drunk driver
and she passed.
And of course, I was devastated,
but with family and faith and Seedlings,
you know, it gave me
things to keep me going.
Lots of people sent memorial donations,
very generous donations in her name.
So, we decided to start
a program to honor her.
And we were selling the books at a loss,
maKing the prices low.
But with this new program
called the Book Angel Program,
we're able to give books away.
And at first it was
just one book per child
in the United States,
and now it's five books for all the kids
in the United States and Canada.
So, we're giving away like two thirds
of the books we send out now.
And it's getting so many
more books in the hands
of the kids with vision loss.
It's just been wonderful.
- That, it is very
wonderful what you're doing,
especially in honor of your daughter.
Thank you, Debra.
I'm loving your post right now.
- Thank you, Kelly, love you.
- Oh, well thank you so much.
But that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So, they're gonna be writing you a check
for Seedlings for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, thank you so much, Debra.
What you're doing is so
cool and so important.
And thank you to all of
our guests this hour.
Daisy Ridley, Lisa
Vanderpump, Hadley Vlahos,
Alana and Lawrence Zarian.
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not, change it.
(rock music)